what exactly can the government do to
him to any of us whether we're on the
watch list or not as a journalist my
first hunch is to go straight to the
source
Michael German is a former FBI agent who
has experience with the terrorism watch
list
what is the internal designation given
to people who are on that watch list
Notre suspected terrorists do you need
to be a known or suspected terrorists to
be given that designation
no you do not there's plenty of evidence
that people were put on these lists were
investigated for no reasons so you're
building this expanding pool of suspects
based on little or no real evidence
what are the most extreme things that
can happen to you if you end up in that
system there's so little transparency
that we don't know all the ways the
watchlist maybe you so from a
deprivation of Rights standpoint there's
a lot you can lose let's say I'm you
know I'm an American citizen i get taken
into secondary screening surely I have
Fourth Amendment protections right not
at the border anything coming across the
border could be contraband and therefore
the government has a right searched it
without work the agents that take me to
secondary screening have the authority
to read the contents of my emails or my
text messages and not just read them but
put them in a database for other agents
across the intelligence community to
read them all of that information and
collectively cross-border so i think a
lot of people are not aware of this what
you're saying that is that at least some
of our Constitution protections don't
exist when we're in a border crossing or
an error
we're coming back from abroad right you
might try going to the airport tomorrow
and see how you do